bonsoir à tous dans un quart d'heure
c'est dans l'air le monde de
l'athlétisme
rattrapé par la corruption et le dopage
l'agencé mondiale antidopage accuse
notamment la russie d'avoir une culture
profondément enraciné de tricherie mais
la corruption touche également les
milieux économiques et politiques et
malheureusement à cet égard la france
vient de perdre quatre places dans les
classements internationaux en matière de
corruption
vous retrouverez yves calvi à 17h48 dans
c dans l'air qui est intitulé ce soir
argent et corruption tout de suite c'est
à dire jean marc jancovici bonsoir vous
êtes ingénieur conseil en saignant à
polytechnique fondateur de carbone 4 et
vous publiez dormez tranquilles jusqu'en
2100 et autre malentendu sur le climat
et l'énergie chez odile jacob autre
malentendu
parce que c'est vrai on dit partout à la
radio on entend que la température va
augmenter de 3 degrés celsius d'ici 2100
et vous dites ça en fait ça n'effraie
personne tout le monde s'en moque 3
degrés de plus d'ici 2100 pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi dites vous ça d'abord
parce que 2100 tout le monde s'en moque
monde sera mort bah vous serez mort vos
enfants seront morts vos petits enfants
seront plus très jeune et d'ici là vous
vous dites que peut-être que vous allez
vous occuper un peu plus de vos
problèmes de court terme donc 2100 ça
fait peur à personne
c'est un peu comme si vous essayez de
motiver un gamin pour aller à l'école
primaire
dès que vous lui dites mais tu sais si
tu travailles bien peut-être qu'à 35 ans
tu seras docteur motivé est encore tôt 3
degrés vous dites c'est vraiment une
façon j'allais dire cool peu effrayant
de prendre le problème alors parce que
parce que les en fait il faut bien voir
qu'une température ça ne parle qu'à nos
sens l'art en ce moment vous êtes en
train de ressentir la température sur ce
plateau tout de suite avec vos sens et
moi avec ma peau je suis pas capable de
savoir quelle est la température qui
fait à sydney et tout de suite là
maintenant à l'instant on se parle ou à
températures en antarctique dans ce
qu'on ressent c'est la température d'ici
tout de suite et cette température là
elle peut varier de beaucoup plus de 3
degrés sans que ça vous fasse rien entre
le point le plus froid de l'hiver est le
point le plus chaud de l'été à paris
vous avez 50 degrés de différence était
toujours bien vivant la preuve on est
tous les deux sur ce plateau convient on
survivre à une robe de grace a fait peur
à personne
en fait ce qu'on comprend pas c'est
qu'ils ont perdu
moyenne c'était un truc au sens ne
perçoivent pas je vais prendre de
nouveau en voir partir à l'école quand
la moyenne d'une classe varient de 5
points ça dit pas du tout la même chose
que quand la note de votre gamin varie
de cinq points la note de votre gamin
qui varient de 5 points vous en tirer
aucune conclusion quant à moyenne varie
cinq points vous en tirer une conclusion
mais là c'est pareil la température
moyenne qui varient de 3 degrés en fait
c'est un énorme changement bien s'en
rend pas compte avec nos sens et pour se
rendre compte qu'il faut remonter très
loin dans le passé il faut revenir à la
dernière ère glaciaire il ya vingt mille
ans au moment au niveau de l'océan a été
plus bas 200 mètres pouvait rentrer à
pied de la grotte cosquer que maintenant
on explore en plongée il y avait cent
mille hommes en france c'est tout ce que
la france était capable de nourrir comme
personne et la différence de température
moyenne avec aujourd'hui c'est moins 5°
c 5 degrés plus froid c'est tout donc 5
degrés de différence sur la moyenne
c'est massif c'est elle on vous dit on
évalue mal même les conséquences pour
l'agriculture nous allons avoir le
ventre vide
alors ce que je dis c'est qu'on va faire
une expérience grandeur nature pour la
première fois et que ça va
vraisemblablement ne pas correspondre à
quelque chose de prévisible quand vous
faites une expérience des fois c'est
prévisible et puis des fois ça n'allait
pas et là on est en train de faire une
expérience dont tous les résultats ne
peuvent pas être prévu alors vous dites
il ya urgence donc comme tout le monde à
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique donc à moins émettre de co2
et donc à moins consommer d'énergies
fossiles
mais ce dont on ne se rend pas tellement
content c'est que les énergies fossiles
vous dites ont été à l'origine d'un
enrichissement considérable de
l'humanité alors est-ce que nous allons
nous appauvrir al'inverse d'une façon
considérable matif au moins utilisé ces
énergies fossiles c'est au sens où on
l'entend classiquement peut-être enfin
qu'en dire au sens du pib peut-être et
au sens le patrimonial peut-être pas
alors je vais essayer d'aller clair ce
qu'ont fait les énergies fossiles c'est
qu'elles ont permis de mettre au travail
à notre place parce qu'avant qu'on et du
gaz du charbon du pétrole
on utilisait nos bras dos jambes un peu
les animaux très un peu le vent dans les
voiles pour les bateaux etc
et puis avec le gaz le pétrole le
charbon on a réussi à mettre au travail
des machines à notre place maintenant
c'est des machines qui cultive ses
détracteurs qui cultive dans les champs
et c'est des usines d'engrais qui font
les engrais c'est à dire qu'ils font
pardonnez moi l'expression la merde du
cheval la place du cheval
quand vous êtes dans une usine c'est pas
les ouvriers qui travaillent les
ouvriers donne des ordres les matches
in qui sont qui font vos vêtements haute
hasbro cuillère vos tables vous mètres
carrés de logements etc
et plus on a des énergies plus on met de
plus en plus de mettre deux machines au
travail et donc plus on peut produire
par personne et c'est très exactement ça
qui a été l'essor de la civilisation
industrielle pendant les deux siècles
qui viennent de s'écouler donc plus
d'énergie fossile c'est plus de
transformation plus de machines qui
travaillent plus de machines qui
travaillent c'est plus d'objets donc
plus de consommation donc au sens où on
l'entend habituellement plus de
richesses donc mais on a bien ouvrir
patrimoine naturel en même temps et donc
si vous faites un compte de patrimoine
avec les objets artificiels créés par
l'homme et la nature qu'on a reçu
gratuitement en héritage là le bilan est
moins claire voilà vous dites pibe égale
co2 donc si à moins de co2 forcément il
y aura moins de pub donc les années
stagnation économique sont devant nous
dit autrement la croissance verte ça
n'existe pas pour voilà exactement alors
il va falloir quand même changer nos
habitudes parce qu'il ya urgence à
réduire les émissions de co2 alors
quelques pistes la voiture électrique
qui remplacerait la voiture à explosion
où l'on brûle du pétrole l'électricité
ça ne pollue pas ça ça dépend comment
vous la faites en france où on a une
électricité qui fait très peu de co2
puisque en france vous avez des trois
quarts qui viennent du nucléaire sur
lequel on peut dire des tas de choses on
en parlera peut-être après mais une
chose qui est sûre c'est que ça fait pas
de co2 les panaches plan qu'on voit au
dessus des grandes tours de
refroidissement c'est juste de la vapeur
d'eau vous savez ça dès que vous avez
une centrale dans laquelle vous avez
beaucoup de chaleur il centrales à
charbon américaines ont les mêmes tours
avec le même panache blanc au dessus
donc vous pouvez la faire avec du
nucléaire en france 75% avec de
l'hydroélectricité 15% avec de l'éolien
5%
tout ça fait pas de co2 reste un petit
quelque chose qui fait du co2 charbon et
gaz mais si vous allez en allemagne la
moitié est faite avec du charbon la
moitié de l'électricité allemande où est
produite avec du charbon billets ça n'a
pas beaucoup changé avec ce que les
allemands ou fait j'avais dix dernières
années et si vous allez en chine c'est
80 % d'électricité qui est faite avec du
charbon de telle sorte que si en chine
vous utilisez une voiture électrique de
masse et de puissance comparable à une
voiture de monsieur tout le monde vous
allait émettre plus de co2 par kilomètre
alors à moins donc ce qu'il faut c'est
produit électricité propre alors vous
êtes regard bader sans carbone donc le
charbon c'est ce qui est pire ou dit
d'ailleurs ça devrait être l'objectif de
la coop 21 éradiquer le charbon oui j'en
viens à une façon de faire d'électricité
propre l'éolien et le solaire
c'est ça la clé l'avenir alors ça
pourrait être l'avenir
si ça ne se heurter pas un obstacle qui
est un obstacle physique extraire de
l'énergie de l'air en mouvement ce qui
est le but de l'éolien c'est beaucoup
plus difficile que d'extraire de
l'énergie d'un gisement de pétrole
oui mais ça pollue pas le pétrole est
déjà concentré j'ai une heure après le
pétrole est déjà concentré sous terre
c'est très facile ça coûte pas cher
alors ça coûte 30 fois moins cher
d'extraire du pétrole du désert saoudien
que d'extraire de l'énergie du vent 30
fois moins cher si vous utilisez des
énergies diffuse donc vous allez avoir
besoin de très gros investissements pour
obtenir la même quantité d'électricité
que si vous utilisez des énergies
concentré bien sûr comme du charbon si
ça fait du co2 ou comme du nucléaire si
ça n'en fait pas et en france si vous
voulez remplacer le nucléaire par un
ensemble et éolien solaire et stockage
ce qu'il faut pouvoir faire cette
émission de télévision même l'hiver
quand ya pas de soleil et même un jour
il ya pas de vent faut que les gens
puissent utiliser le train pour aller au
travail même un jour il n'y a pas de
vent et même à un moment il n'y a pas de
soleil
si vous rajoutez la fonction stockage la
fonction système on va dire en gros vous
avez besoin d'investir 10 à 40 fois plus
si vous faites un ensemble totalement
éolien solaire et stockage que si vous
faites dans le système actuel
alors voilà vous dites donc le solaire
ou l'éolien c'est 10 à 40 fois plus cher
oui que le nucléaire est donc vous dites
au fond on a besoin nucléaire c'est 10 à
40 fois plus d'investissements
investissement alors le nucléaire deux
objections la première fukushima alors
fukushima est quelque chose qui a fait
très peur est en fait qui n'a pas faim
dont un accident nucléaire
une catastrophe je vais y venir le
charbon tue chaque année 300 mille
personnes dans le monde
trois cent mille personnes la ville de
grenoble éradiquer tous les ans le
charbon la voiture tue un million de
personnes par an tous les ans dans le
monde où la cigarette c'est du même
ordre de grandeur
fukushima n'a pas fait un mort à cause
du surplus de radiation relâchées dans
l'environnement et c'est pas moi qui ai
dit c'est déjà sympa un mois zéro mort
fou mais c'est les nations unies qui le
disent
vous êtes sûr de ça je suis sûr parce
que c'est les nations unies qui me
disent vous avez et j'en parle aussi
dans ce livre un organisme onusien qui
s'appelle lune ce qu'est arles nom et
barbare ça veut dire united nations
scientific committee andy effects of
atomic radiations c'est la même chose
que le giec
le giec étudie le climat il
écrit en 88 lune ce quillard étudie la
radioactivité créant 55
l'une sera rendu en avril 2014 un
rapport sur fukushima en disant
fukushima ne fera pas un mort à cause du
surplus de radiation dernier et puis
après tout comment relancer mais c'est
passionnant votive les déchets qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait des déchets nos
petits-enfants montrer coltiner ces
déchets radioactifs
oui mais j'ai vraiment pas un sujet si
vous confie nsa dans un stockage
géologique ça va y rester très longtemps
vous avez un gisement de pétrole
c'est un confinement géologique de
pétrole sous pression
ça peut durer 50 millions d'années donc
des déchets qui doivent être confinés
pendant quelques milliers d'années ce
n'est pas un sujet merci beaucoup jean
marc jancovici donc il ya des tas de
vous démonter des tas d'idées reçues
dans ce livre dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 et autre malentendu sur le
climat et l'énergie c'est chez odile
jacob merci
restez avec nous tout de suite yves
calvi c dans l'air le monde de
l'athlétisme rattrapé par le scandale du
dopage et de la corruption
la russie notamment est accusé d'avoir
une culture de tricherie profondément
enracinée c'est dans l'air est intitulé
ce soir argent et corruption